well the rise in covet cases in clark  county has health officials on alert  the delta variant has been reported in  over 140 cases in nevada  according to the southern nevada health  district face mask will not be mandated  at this point  instead the focus is getting everyone  that is eligible to get vaccinated  especially young adults  dr farming leguin with the health  district says they will continue to  provide  convenient vaccine clinics in the valley  we consider that it is very important  for us to  emphasize the need for vaccination  for those people who have not received a  vaccine because  most of the the hospitalizations and  deaths that we are seeing today in dry  county  are from people who who are not  vaccinated  and a reminder there is a chance of  getting the virus even if you are fully  vaccinated so the end goal  is to get as many people as possible to  get vaccinated  to stop the spread